[Music]
hey not going to be home tonight you'll
be all
[Music]
right
Jimmy something happened tonight you'll
work out with Cal where you're going to
go who the hell is Cal where is
Eddie I'm
Cal is Eddie okay you know what Eddie is
he's a thief yes I know what Eddie
is is anybody
looking everyone's looking and they're
looking for you
too you're not to talk to anyone I've
never been on my own you want Somebody
to
Love Don't you need somebody to
[Music]
love shut the kid
[Applause]
up
this was your family's I'm Terry Cal's
wife anyone can learn to shoot but what
you really need to figure out is what
you'll do when it's
real why did art show me how to use a
gun I just thought you should be
prepared for what comes
next what comes
next
this is no place for a
child this can all be
[Music]
over
oh